bonjour à toutes et à tous nouvel
épisode nouveau mystère je pense que
nous sommes parés pour traiter du rwanda
vision la dernière fois j'avoue avoir
été assez perturbé car au final même si
l'épisode était cool bas il n'y avait
pas quelque chose d'incroyable en termes
de mystère n'y avait pas de grandes
révélations en fait wendat vision et par
moments prisonnier de son côté parodique
car évidemment en rendant hommage à des
sites comme eh bien il faut prendre le
temps d'amener le côté humoristique
faire des références et c'est là
aujourd'hui on était sur the office
baisse sitcom et je pense sincèrement
que nous sommes sur le dernier hommage
car au vu du temps restant il ne reste
plus que deux épisodes
eh bien il va falloir balance et là il
va falloir envoyer du lourd et conclure
tout d'abord j'aimerais revenir sur un
point que je n'avais pas spécialement
détailler la semaine dernière car je ne
le trouvais pas suffisamment pertinent
mais qui mérite aujourd'hui d'être
souligné et world un projet avec vision
on ne sait pas quoi exactement mais on
se doute fortement que ce n'est pas
quelque chose de bienveillant hayward
semble considérer vision simplement
comme une arme et n'hésitera pas à faire
des dommages collatéraux pour arriver à
ses fins et c'est là que c'est
intéressant car il est tout à fait
possible qu'au final hayward est était
un argument majeur pour que wendat
utilise entre guillemets west view
encourager très certainement par
quelqu'un comme agyness wendat aurait
usé de la réalité de west view pour
protéger les gens qu'elle aime comme
vision ce qui expliquerait pourquoi sa
colère envers le sword
elle connaissait déjà le symbole au
début de la série et pour parler plus
précisément de vision il va y avoir un
énorme travail de développement dans
le couple vision a été en quelque sorte
formaté après tout il a été tué et même
rtu et donc voilà il ne se rappelle de
rien ce qui logiquement veut dire que
wayne dallas en quelque sorte obligé à
l'est mais par le biais de west view est
ce qui explique pourquoi il souhaite
absente et souvent néanmoins darcis lui
a bien rappelé son histoire et ça va
très clairement je pense lui faire
changer sa vision des choses
ouais je veux la garder au montage celle
là bon maintenant je suppose que vous
souhaitez fortement que nous parlions de
ces fameuses révélations de l'épisode 7
et bien je vous avoue que
personnellement je suis assez intrigué
depuis le début on suppose tout stagnait
ce serait en fait agata harkness
néanmoins ces actes ne correspondent pas
trop personnage d'origine ce qui fait
que le doute était largement permis ce
que je veux dire c'est que dans les
comics agata n'est pas quelqu'un de
mauvais et au contraire elle l'aide les
avengers est laide wendat qu'elle
considérerait même comme une sorte de
filles spirituelles
pour ceux qui ne seraient pas
spécialement familier avec le personnage
agata harkness fait partie d'une
douzaine de sorcières et sorciers les
plus puissants de la terre
elle engendrera même un fils qui se
retournera contre elle elle a pris
également au rwanda sous son aile pour
l'aider à maîtriser ses pouvoirs
instable et c'est quelque chose que l'on
retrouve dans le mc de honda possède un
pouvoir qui la dépasse et ces mêmes
agatha qui orientera et conseillera au
rwanda à se marier avec vision et avoir
des enfants
alors que ce dernier est un synthé zoïde
alors je vous avoue que l'a révélé en
tant que grande méchante de one la
vision me perturbe assez et je pense
qu'il doit y avoir un gros mystère
derrière tout ça si nous réfléchissons
logiquement au rwanda contrôle west view
et si à
ness est présente et agi pour aider
wendat c'est qu'il ya quelque chose qui
l'intéresse chez wang d'ajustement pour
moi il y a deux cas de figure dans la
réécriture des comics pour l'adapter au
mc eu peut-être est-il trop tôt pour
faire apparaître méphisto à l'écran et
agathe à prendre est en quelque sorte la
relève
on ne va pas se mentir je pense qu
agatha a fait disparaître les enfants de
wendat comme dans les comics où ils se
sont révélés être des fragments d'âme de
méphisto la agatha du mc us serait une
méphisto bis et si elle a bien fait ça
aux enfants bat assez clairement une
déclaration de guerre envers rwanda
néanmoins dans le mc eu elles ne se
connaissent pas encore réellement bon ok
haguenets s'est présenté comme la
méchante mais est ce que ce ne serait
pas pour le show les personnages brise
le quatrième mur très souvent entre le
fait de parler à la caméra ou faire des
interviews comme à l'asie office si
agyness conserve les mêmes traits de
caractère que agatha dans les comics
peut-être chercheur est elle au final à
aider ou honda a manipulé ses pouvoirs
peut-être at-elle besoin d' aide par
rapport à un truc spécifique de magie vu
que rwanda est une sorcière
enfin bref par rapport à tout ça j'ai
deux idées en rapport avec agathe
harkness justement tout d'abord ce livre
je suis prêt mais à le parier
ce livre est le fruit tome qui renferme
le démon sommeil où ça mène tout dépend
de comment voulu le prononcé pour faire
simple c'est une entité très ancienne
qui peut faire des projections dans le
temps lancer des sorts
il est lié au pays des maures bref tout
ce que vous pouvez imaginer un démon ce
démon a été confronté à oujda dans son
histoire dans les comics et au vu du
gros plan sur le livre ça me laisse
présager l'idée que wendat pourrait s'y
confronter également dans le mc et
deuxième idée
dans une idée de réadaptation des comics
agata serait donc la méchante et il y a
moyen de remanier des choses des comics
et ce pour au rwanda visible dans les
comics du coup agatha et est installée à
salem une ville un petit peu spéciale où
les habitants au des pouvoirs magiques
etc
c'est un petit peu comme sabrina quoi
agathe à l'avenir quittera la ville pour
s'installer ailleurs
et malheureusement un gros incident va
arriver dans la ville de salem agata
sera tenu pour responsable est traqué
par les habitants et sera même brûlé sur
un bûcher rwanda et visions tenteront de
s'interposer pour aider agatha mais dans
la bataille le sorcier ennemis vertigo
perd le contrôle de ses pouvoirs et tue
tous les villageois par erreur est ce
que vous voyez l'idée dans cette théorie
dans le mc eu du coup rwanda qui a le
contrôle de west view justement pourrait
retourner la ville contre agatha est
donc la faire tomber quoi les choses ne
se passent pas comme prévu et rwanda est
obligé de se battre mais vu que c'est
pouvoir la dépasse et sont même décuplé
dans west view elle perdrait le contrôle
et détruirait toute la ville mettant fin
en fin à ce calvaire qui est west view
mais amène quand même un sort assez
macabre mais bon cela reste une idée
comme ça
concernant monica elle a donc ses
pouvoirs c'était quelque chose d'attendu
même si je ne pensais pas que ce serait
est arrivé dans word à vision monica est
donc la première personne à être rentrés
sans le consentement de rwanda ce qui
lui a donné ses pouvoirs en quelque
sorte avec la barrière du x
j'admets ne pas trop avoir de
suppositions sur son cas pour le moment
pour les noms familiers
en gros monica rambo est une sorte de
captain marvel en beaucoup moins
puissante
donc voilà si pouvoir se rapprochent
entre guillemets de ceux de carole
évidemment au rwanda la prend pour une
ennemie mais ça ira très certainement
avec elle quand elle sera au bout du
rouleau et visions l'aidera sûrement là
dedans aussi
étant donné qu'il a échangés avec darcy
et dort s'y connaît money can et je
n'oublie pas le caméo de l'épisode 9 qui
doit forcément arriver pour moi je reste
sur strange personnellement et en plus
strange est en quelque sorte un sorcier
voilà il fait les arts mystiques et
cetera donc il colle parfaitement à la
situation et le thème entre guillemets
et puis toute façon il est lié forcément
à oujda qui apparaîtra dans doctor
strange de beaucoup suspectent également
magnéto et bah je vous avoue que je ne
comprends pas trop pourquoi
magnéto est présenté dans les comics
comme le père du rwanda est un
personnage quand même ikonik chez
limitant sauf que le problème bas rwanda
a déjà des parents dans l'uem cu et bah
elle n'est pas une mutante non plus s'il
adapte eric launcher à l'écran je vous
avoue que je comprends pas trop le
délire quoi c'est comme si on réadapter
batman mais en le faisant tuer des gens
attends quoi non en vrai ce rôle un peu
je vous taquine mais voilà je
comprendrais pas trop qu'il y ait
magnéto pour moi je pense qu'il faut
attendre l'arrivée des mutants parce que
magnéto en plus est quand même une
figure emblématique chez les mutants
quoi ce serait un peu gâché le
personnage que le faire arriver sans le
lier aux huit ans etc
enfin voilà j'espère que la vidéo de la
semaine suivante la vision vous aura plu
si c'est le cas n'hésitez pas comme
toujours à me le faire savoir dans les
commentaires avec vos théories vos idées
vos avis c'est au jour un véritable
plaisir que de vous lire n'hésitez pas
également à vous abonner à la chaîne a
laissé un petit pouce bleus voilà ça me
soutient ça fait plaisir
et puis bah voila quoi on se retrouve
très vite pour de nouvelles vidéos
écouter c'est et argue rock et que le
liner a soit avec vous allez ciao tout
le monde
[Musique]